[Music]
what is joshua becker's definition of
minimalism how does it differ from the
minimalists definition
ah this is great that's good yeah and so
we're not gonna differ are we i love how
you literally maybe we will literally in
your book you're like my definition of
minimalism is oh man i uh remember
making by the book to find out i
remember sitting at a computer writing
it i remember where i was when i wrote
out my definition of minimalism i don't
know that they're different we'll talk
about them i think the essence is the
same i think the definition might be
different but what really matters is the
essence of it talking about what when
you talk about
when you tell someone what minimalism is
what do you tell them
uh minimalism is the intentional
promotion of the things we most value in
life
by removing anything that distracts us
from it um that's beautiful
it's brilliant i mean on the surface
minimalism i think in terms of
what i'm known for writing about is
about owning less stuff about owning
just what you need to live out your
purpose but that looks very different
from one person to another and so
i found in my own pursuit that not only
did minimalism force me to define my
values
you don't know what you need to keep
unless you know what you want to
accomplish with your life
but it also uh freed me up to do more of
that as i remove distractions so and
then as i saw it play out in other areas
of life then it the definition became
what it is today
the solid definition we ryan and i talk
about minimalism being the thing that
gets us past the thing so we can make
room for life's most important things
which aren't things at all and so while
that's pithy and tweetable the the his
answer is so elegant the definition
they're so elegant allows you to really
expand on that yeah um
when we're talking about removing
distractions your new book
is about that by the way and you've
written about this for years over at
becomingminimalist.com
which is
the blog one of the blogs that really
inspired me and ryan to begin to
simplify our lives
and in the book though you identify
the eight major distractions in life
and i thought we'd go through those
together
if you're willing beautiful all right
all of them
all eight we're gonna read all eight
chapters oh we're gonna read all eight
chapters this is gonna turn into an
audio book
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel one hundred
percent advertisement free